foreign
let's go to Steven in Springfield what's
up Steven
hey guys thanks for taking my call you
got it what's up dude
oh so I got a question on
um kind of how to handle I ended up
taking on Saturdays at work
um so I'm bringing home about an extra
350 a week
um I got about 26 000 in
um Consumer Debt uh through different
loans and everything like that uh with
different interest rates so I'm just
trying to figure out every time I seem
to have extra money I throw it across
the board and I'm trying to figure out
if it's better to just say pick one pay
it off then roll it or what is your guys
input on something like that so what
kind of debts are these if you listed
out the 26.
so I've got a car
um credit card
um between me and my wife and then
um I have a Peloton spin bike that has a
zero percent so I kind of always throw
that one on the back burner and try to
go after the car that has a 5.4 percent
and the credit card that has an 14
um but then again every time I put a
thousand dollars on the credit card
something comes up and it feels like
that thousands back on there
can we can we agree before George walks
you through it that the way you're doing
is not working
correct absolutely yes dude you're
you've already won you've already won
congratulations all right uh as a as a
fellow math nerd on paper you're like
well I should pay off the highest
interest at first that makes sense
mathematically I'll pay the least amount
of interest but what we found is that
personal finance is 80 Behavior it's
only 20 nerdy head knowledge and so the
way we've seen it where people actually
get this debt out of their life once and
for all is using the debt snowball
method which is ignoring the interest
rate just cross it out you don't know
the interest rates anymore all you see
is individual balances we're going to
pay minimum payments on all of the
balances except for that smallest one
and with all that side work all of the
extra money your cutting expenses
selling stuff you're gonna throw that
the smallest debt it's going to free up
a payment you're going to roll it to the
next one and the next one and man that
is the fastest way now is it
mathematically the best way no you
probably could save a few dollars on
interest but you'll also probably hang
on to that debt for longer because it's
hard to make progress
yeah and that's exactly where I feel
like I'm at right now and that's totally
been listening to you guys more and more
and just been trying to tackle it and I
figured here we are and let's try to see
what you guys input on it is there's
something I mean there's something
powerful Stephen about this you have a
debt with 500 you have a debt with 300
you have a loan to a buddy for 1500
bucks you got a credit card with five
thousand dollars
and you get a thousand bucks and you
throw it at that car
and it goes down to four thousand
you still all owe all the same people
money
correct
there's something else if you owed six
people money and you took that thousand
bucks and you paid off that 300 one in
that 500 one you just cut two sharks out
of your life
there's something powerful
psychologically
like I'm actually making progress when
you just knock five thousand to four
thousand that's a lot of money but it
doesn't feel that like it because you're
still paying the same people there's
something about knocking these things
out smallest to largest that you start
to believe I can do this and then I like
it this is me personally I like that
credit card just hanging out there just
gnawing at you 14 like it just gives you
it gives you hemorrhoids there's no
Preparation H in sight you're just gonna
you gotta deal with it it makes you I
gotta get that thing out of my life but
the only way I get it is to get these
other three out and so I'm just gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna power through does
that make sense
absolutely yeah because I'm gearing up
for tax returns and stuff like that and
my issue at hand was all right well how
am I going to use that money
um if I do get any or I always try to
break even but you know some years you
end up getting something back and I'm
just hoping that if I do I wanted to use
it in the right way instead of year
after year feeling like I'm just putting
a thousand dollars across the board and
like you guys are saying I still have
three other debts that just have a
little bit lower of a balance yeah dude
you know what to do man commit to this
debt snowball and you're going to be
debt free in no time
very cool I appreciate that you got it
brother hey holler at us when you uh get
all these paid off man and we'll
celebrate with you